- [Narrator] What if I told you,
you can literally eat fire?
Yes, literally.
(upbeat music)
In India, paan is a huge culinary darling
that's been around for centuries.
It's a snack usually eaten after a meal
to help with digestion.
It consists of a betel
of leaf that's wrapped
around all kinds of different fillings,
like nuts, fennel, cardamom, fruits,
chocolate, or even meat.
You can find it anywhere.
But a small street food shack in New Delhi
is sparking a revolution.
- [Narrator] All right, then.
But back to the revolution he's sparking.
Recently, he had an idea that
would reignite the classic
Indian snack his shack was famous for.
- [Narrator] I have a
burning question for you:
Is it safe to eat?
- [Narrator] You're really
bringing on the heat.
OK, that was a slow-burner.
I was just warming up.
OK, OK, we've already
burned too much time.
(crickets chirping)
- [Narrator] So, there you have it.
India's hottest trend.
(upbeat music)